hey everyone bandit here you're all
following me on twitter right yeah of
course you are
link is in the description below well if
you recall a few days ago i had tried to
summon news on breath of the wild sequel
for the 2021 game awards but alas it
seems i didn't use enough summon juice
because the game awards which streamed
live this past friday to fans all over
the world has come to an end and lo and
behold it did not hold any new
information for the legend of zelda
franchise much less the sequel to breath
of the wild much less anything nintendo
for that matter except for a few
nintendo switch ads which each gave me a
huge heart attack every time i heard
that
even though the current president of
nintendo doug bowser and the former
president reggie the man were both
present and even on the stage at
different times in the event ultimately
their appearances were simply to claim
the best action-adventure game for
metrodred which was amazing and present
one of the categories winners and that
was it everything else was kind of
but i believe that the lack of nintendo
or zelda anything present at the game
awards is actually a good thing and
could mean that we have huge things in
store coming up soon when you look at
the big picture and speaking of the big
picture news about the sequel is so big
at this point that i can't cover this
alone my dear little bandits please
welcome once again to the channel the
one and only conrad from the
commonwealth realm take it away sir hi
everyone good to be back on mnb be sure
to check out the other part of this
collaborative video a proper zelda
theory that's live right now on my
channel after finishing up here anyway i
want to first briefly point out and
explain the elephant in the room
regarding zelda news at tga this past
friday no nintendo did not promise or
even hints that anything will be
happening at the event so why were there
so many people expecting news you might
be wondering while the misled
expectations actually did not come from
nintendo themselves but rather from a
combination of two main factors one
nintendo of america's bill trinin who
told ign in an interview this past june
that they would be quote starting to
show a bit more of the game over the
coming months to the next year or so
with the coming months in 2021 being the
key takeaway from this quote 2. jeff
keeley aka the game award man himself
said that there will be a game
development reveal that had been worked
on for two and a half years and most
zelda fans already know that pretty much
exactly two and a half years have passed
since the day the first trailer for
breath the world 2 was dropped and
subsequently shattered the internet with
overloads of hype with these two factors
present in everyone's minds in addition
to nintendo's strange overall silence
regarding zelda's 35th anniversary this
year it didn't take long for people to
begin to place their hopes in the game
awards which is the final large gaming
event of the year of course we know that
it all meant nothing in the end that
being said though this lack of
information about the game is actually
typical of nintendo's recent development
cycle i mean does anyone even remember
metroid prime 4 at this point have
definitely decided to keep most of their
projects completely under wraps in
recent years choosing instead to
randomly reveal large new games in their
own standalone nintendo direct
presentations so honestly nintendo's
lack of presence at the game awards was
quite predictable if you look at it
objectively well since we know that
zelda's not being at the game awards
doesn't necessarily mean anything bad
about the sequel's release date or
timeline let's ask the other question
now does it mean anything good like i
said at the start of this video i think
it does quite a bit actually ask
yourself in what stage of development is
the sequel to breath of the wild
currently can we tell what stage it's in
you might be tempted to say that there's
no way of possibly knowing for sure and
you'd be partially right but remember
that nintendo revealed a new trailer to
us this summer that featured for the
first time a release date for the game
well uh release year man we have a
release here but no name isn't that wild
anyway you don't need to know that much
about video game development to know
that they normally take multiple years
to develop and within those years as you
could imagine there is a whole lot going
on but games have been around now for
many decades the game development
pattern has been studied and scrutinized
and simplified for us little people to
understand and it usually inhabits seven
overarching steps with the last two
steps happening after the game releases
if we take this development timeline
graph as an example we can see that
since we've been able to watch some
trailers and hype building pieces of
media about breath of the wild too it
must then be in the fourth developmental
stage pre-launch in this stage the game
has already been built it's already gone
through vigorous nintendo quality levels
of testing and even has some alpha build
sent out to quality assurance testers
what this all means is that by the time
we the fans start to see trailers and
other forms of marketing about a game
the game itself is literally one step
away from launching to the public at
least generally speaking and with breath
of the wild 2 we got the second
marketing trailer this year in addition
to the developmental patterns we're able
to observe as fans they're also the
pattern that nintendo has previously
taken when developing the first breath
of the wild according to some sources
the game could have started its planning
phase as early as the release of skyward
sword in 2011. with it then releasing in
2017 we can assume that the entire
development psych for breath the wild
took about five six years in total and
next year it will be 2022 five years
after breath dwarfs release so if we
follow patterns nintendo should have
been able to build an entire other world
of the same size and variability as
breath the world's hyrule since 2017 and
i think they have indeed done just that
now what does this mean in light of no
zelda content that the game awards well
logically i think it means that nintendo
is in this pre-launch stage of
development for a sequel and that
nintendo already has plans on when and
how it will reveal the next bit of
information about the game and
ultimately release it to the public they
must have heard enormous amounts of
chatter online about fans expecting to
hear something about zelda after all it
was trending on twitter like 10 times or
so i think nintendo could even pull what
would be the ultimate hype and sale
building move and choose to finally
reveal the title for the sequel at the
same time they release it to the public
or perhaps just reveal the finalized
release date now if only we know what
the title of the game might be but i'm
getting ahead of myself that's what our
other video is about so please feel free
to check it out when this one ends in
just a few minutes
so to summarize this video in a couple
of sentences basically what we're trying
to say is that it was disappointing that
there was no zelda at the game awards
but it actually wasn't nintendo's fault
this time on the other hand it could
actually mean that nintendo is in
complete control and has some sort of
brilliant professional developer plan
for releasing the game in the next year
in a way that will build even more hype
than we've ever seen before even in 2019
and it could be closer than we think
which ultimately led to them deciding
not to talk about it at the game awards
to be honest with you i think that given
the previous pattern of nintendo directs
we could be looking at a january to
february direct which would of course be
revealed to the public probably one or
two days before it goes live you know in
classic nintendo fashion and if the
speculations of this video are true that
means that nintendo has big zeld-shaped
things in store but until then we've
just gotta remember to keep our hopes in
check and hype responsibly because
nobody wants to be let down even after
watching this prediction video and i'm
preaching to myself there too but hey
that's just our theory about what's
going to happen or what's currently
happening at the big n what do you guys
think does nintendo have a genius plan
to reveal new information about breath
of the wild soon or did they just miss
out on a big opportunity to score some
awesome viewers for the game and will
now have to do some damage control for
disappointing their fans and killing
some of the hype let me know what you
think in the comments below also thank
you so much for watching and a huge
thanks to conrad from commonwealth rum
for joining me on this one as he
mentioned earlier there is the sequel if
you will to this video over on his
channel that's live right now
take that nintendo so please check it
out via the description below and be
sure to leave a like on this video if
you enjoyed our predictions and
subscribe if you haven't already to
stick around for so many more
interesting gaming videos to come huge
thanks as always to my banner crew who
make my day every single day that's all
i've got in this one so as always i hope
you have a wonderful rest of your day
this is massent and abandoned looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out peace
[Music]
you